[Music]
fact remains right now russia has more
than 150 000 troops encircling ukraine
and belarus and along ukraine's border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
the largest troop built up since the
second world war the intent has not
not gone away and nor have the troops
gotten away
it must have been a serious
seriously thought act plan
that existed probably before april and
was then refined in april after april
you just do not do things like this for
nothing
he's brought all the
all the minor things to the to to the
border he's bought
field hospitals blood
logistics you name it it's all there in
in the game and aircraft of course
you've got a combined arms army
effectively
uh plus an air a major air wing in
crimea
there's enough troops in there now for a
major a major push either towards odessa
or behind the troops that are lined up
in the donbas
around the corner but behind donetsk
you've got another combined arms army a
lot of their equipment and troops have
actually been pushing into donetsk
inside belarussia they are in a
condition during the exercise to just
turn right or left and go straight down
one of the roads towards towards kiev
there's nine vessels major vessels
carrying vessels somewhere in the in the
black sea doing
doing what
the russia that came
in 2014 was
was actually a bit of a ragtag and
bobtail army
um
you know you you see you see trains
coming and
complete mix of equipment and they're
missing a gun out of a battery now what
do we see this time
coherence real coherence when the
train's coming with a with a battalion
group that battalion group is coherent
you